you know hello this is Adam Smith
calling from nobelprize.org the website
of the Nobel Prize for sale first of all
many congratulations on the award of the
Nobel Prize well thank you very much and
I'm over the moon actually where were
you when you got the news um i was i was
working at my desk at home I sometimes
work in the mornings here what I tend to
do is I try and get as much writing it
at work I much I get as much writing
done at home before i go into work what
was your first reaction on the receiving
the call I that was terrific I thought
it was you know III I had just been to
Oslo a couple of weeks ago to receive
the cavity prize and I thought oh this
couldn't possibly view what I think it
is but but of course it was so I'm
absolutely delighted of course and then
it's tremendous honor and it is it is
the Acme of a scientific crisis and I
think it said now I'm very humbled by
the whole thing but I'm delighted for us
and you know your car door is very well
indeed the Moses yes they came they came
I I had known them actually for many
many years I knew them when they were
students with tara anderson in oslo and
they were already clearly destined to be
to be stars and i was delighted when
they they wanted to come and spend some
time in my laboratory to learn some of
some of our techniques and i think
they's they put them to good use on my
face it's 43 years since you first found
these place cells in the hippocampus I
suppose the lesson from that is that one
has to be pretty patient in unraveling
them yes I think I have a reputation for
being patient yeah actually I hadn't
realized it was that long but it is yes
it's it's a 42 43 years and I have to
say in the beginning most people were
quite skeptical um no idea that you
could go deep inside the brain
and find things which correspond it to
two aspects of the environment surviving
people were a little bit surprised and
skeptical about that um I think it's
taking a while but then that there were
some people early on who accepted it and
of course very grateful and of course
now the field has has blossomed and it's
a and i think that the prize actually
there's much for the field as myself in
the moses at meetings you know we're
just represented in a large number of
people who are working away at the
hippocampus and memory and station
navigation yes there must be an enormous
number of happy people around today yeah
okay well thank you very much indeed I
hope you have a most splendid day and
are you still at home are you still I'm
hiding at home yet probably wise to do
that for as long as you care what we're
gonna course in contact with the people
in my office in love with proposing to
do with the set up press conference
probably at the Wellcome Trust media
center which is up the road from
University College one problem afternoon
I think so so I have another hour stay
relatively low key in that yes and avoid
too many glass of champagne oh yeah let
me do that okay all right well many many
congratulations and thank you very much
thank you very much Adam thank you
bye-bye